welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital images part
4 the right format for the right job
so what i want to talk about in this
video is different image formats that
you might use
i'm going to focus primarily on formats
that are used on the web
in this little diagram here we can see
the primary formats that are used on the
web
there's one object format that's used on
the web and that's svg
it's relative newcomer to use on the web
although it has been around for a while
it has a lot of similarities to html so
i'm going to hold off discussing how it
actually works and what it looks like
until
after we've talked about html later in
the quarter html is the primary way of
specifying
the contents of a web page so we'll be
covering html when we cover web pages
which is probably in about four weeks or
so the main thing to be thinking about
as far as svg goes is
if you can describe your image using a
bunch of different geometric shapes
svg is a great format we talked about
that last video how
object also known as vector formats for
images are very compact
they have a lot of nice properties as
far as editing goes being able to zoom
in to the image
and so this is a great choice if the
particular image that
you're working with will fit into the
object format
we also talked about how for a lot of
uses
the bitmap format is a much better
choice and in particular
if we've got something like a photograph
the object
slash vector format is not going to work
and so we would want to use a bitmap
format
also the bitmap formats has just
traditionally been used much more widely
on the web
there is an older object format called
flash which was used
primarily for advertising but also for
fun little games that were on the web
but it's been on its way out for quite a
while
and i do expect that it's going to be
replaced completely by svg
all right so we've got a number of
different bitmap formats
in addition to the three main formats
used on the web jpeg png and gif
there are a couple other formats that
you might be interested in
raw and heic heic is the format that
apple uses
when you take a photograph with an
iphone it's going to be stored in heic
format
and raw is a format that's specifically
used on high-end cameras now neither of
these
formats is available for use on the web
so you're going to have to convert from
either raw or heic to one of the other
formats that we're going to be talking
about today
but i do think that raw and hcic are
going to be potentially
interesting and useful for some of you
so we are going to touch on them briefly
today
all right so the bitmap format is
concerned with
what is the individual value of each of
the colors for each of the pixels
that compose the image now one thing
that you might be thinking is
well isn't there just one bitmap format
you're either remembering things as
objects and you can kind of picture how
we could have possibly different object
formats on the basis of
well how complicated do we want to get
do we want to just be able to support
you know ovals and rectangles or do we
want to get super complicated and do
things like spline curves
and there are actually a wide range of
different object formats that are
proprietary
svg is just the one that's actually
widely supported for web use
but as far as bitmap formats isn't it
just a matter of we just remember all
the individual pixel values and what the
colors are for those pixels
well it turns out that it's actually a
bit more complicated than that
even though ultimately we are trying to
remember what the different values for
all the individual pixels is
it turns out that there are different
ways of representing the same
information so what we're going to do
now is we're going to take a look at
this example with the h that we we saw
previously
when we were talking about black and
white monitors so
i've got an h here on my macbook pro
and i want to know how to describe
what is being displayed on the screen
suppose for example
i'm trying to describe this h to one of
my tas when we're talking over the phone
how can i do that
well the standard approach uh is to just
think of this as
a straight grid with a whole bunch of
pixels and i just go ahead and read off
each of the pixel values so i say
oh zero zero is off one zero is off
two zero's off and i proceed to read the
entire first line which is all off
i move to the second line um you'll
notice that these numbers actually start
with zero zero that's pretty common in
computer science
um so the next the next line is line one
so i would say oh zero one is off
one one is off two one is off and so on
i would get to the
the third row which is uh number two
since we're starting with zero zero one
two
um and i say oh zero two's off one two's
off three two's on
four two is off five two is on 62 is off
and your party probably already sick of
of hearing this
and believe me if i were actually
reading all these values over the phone
to the ta they would be very very sick
of it
one and two it would be super easy for
them to accidentally
get one of these on or off wrong so
this this particular approach works but
talking over the phone and describing it
is obviously very time consuming
and similarly storing all these
individual pixel values
is going to take a lot of space on on
the computer
so this is an ideal is there a better
way to do this well yeah actually it is
there is
let's take a look at the second approach
here okay so here is a second approach
to describing the exact same screen
i'm talking to the ta over the telephone
i say oh
row zero it's all off row one
is the same as row zero row two is the
same as row
zero except for 2 2 and 4 2 are both on
row 3 is the same as row 2 except for 3
3 is on as well
and row 4 is the same as row 2 and all
the other rows are
exactly the same as row 0. okay so i've
described the exact same scene
and the ta is able to get the exact same
amount of information as if i had read
off all the individual pixel values
but you can see that this is a much more
compact way of describing the exact same
situation
and so it does turn out that there are
different ways that i can describe what
all the individual pixels are
and the first approach where i actually
just read off all the individual pixel
values
this is a format that's sometimes
referred to as bmp or bitmap format
and it works but it's very large
and because it takes up a fair amount of
space in order to do it that means if we
download it for the internet it's going
to take a fair amount of time
and therefore we don't use that format
it's going to turn out that two out of
the three formats that we're going to be
talking about today
actually use a very similar approach to
my compact version where i said hey you
know that row is exactly
the same as this other row that we've
already seen and by
combining our rows together and saying
hey this is the same something you've
already seen
we're able to greatly reduce the amount
of space this takes
this is sometimes referred to as
compression because we've taken
the information that we started off with
we've changed the format
that we're using to describe that
information and in changing the format
we've reduced the amount of space it
takes so this is referred to as
compression
okay so the first of our file formats
that we're going to be looking at is
jpeg
jpeg stands for joint photographics
experts group which is the name of the
group that came up with this particular
format but
i'm guessing 90 of the people that
use this format have no idea what it
stands for it's just called jpeg
jpeg is designed to store photographs so
if you've got a photograph you should
probably use jpeg in fact
most consumer cameras and most cell
phones
pre iphone switching to heic
just when you take a photograph it just
immediately converts it to jpeg
with iphones if you want to
put it on the web or you want to send it
to somebody that doesn't have an iphone
you're going to need to convert it to
jpeg often
the applications are going to
immediately convert it to jpeg
automatically for you so if you're going
to text a
post a photograph to a friend and they
don't have an iphone it will
automatically get
converted to jpeg now jpeg stores 24-bit
color so that means you have the full
16.7 million color range
it does have an interesting
drawback that we'll see doesn't show up
with all the techniques we're going to
be using
jpeg is what we refer to as a lossy
compression format so what this means is
this
actually loses information i've got two
images of
venice here and on the left hand side
i've got a 1944 by 2592
image of venice and this is 1.39
megabytes and on the right side
i have 1944 by 2592 again
same pixel resolution but this image on
the right is only 215 kilobytes so
the image on the right is 1 6 the size
of the image on the left
now if we're looking at these how many
of you can tell the difference between
these two images
so we're going to do is we're going to
go ahead and zoom in and we're going to
take
a close look at just one section of the
image
now if you look at this rail running
along the top of the building here on
the right
you'll notice that the rail on the image
on the left that's the large size image
you can actually see the rail pretty
pretty easily and on the right side of
the image it's just kind of this big old
mess
similarly if you look at the guy wires
holding up the edifice on the right side
they're kind of messed up and on the
left side you can tell that they
actually are wires
you can also see if you look along the
edge of the roof
you can see that on the left it looks
clean and on the right it just kind of
jumbled up
so we're seeing here is these are jpeg
compression artifacts
whenever you use jpeg you are losing
information
so as soon as you snap that camera
you're losing information
and you're getting these jpeg
compression artifacts but the thing
about jpeg is we can control
how much compression actually occurs so
we can say oh
i want my image to look pretty close to
what the camera's actually seeing
so i'm gonna i'm going to sacrifice some
space i'm going to have a very
large jpeg file with very little
compression artifacts or i could say
you know this thing's going to go up on
the web and i don't think anybody's
really going to notice of that guy wire
or that
that railing along the edge of that roof
is a little bit messed up nobody's going
to notice and i want a nice small image
so that
it will easily quickly download on the
web
so um apple's new heic format
also does compression it does a better
job with compression than jpeg it's
newer format
if you don't want any compression at all
to take place if you wanted to snap that
image with your camera
and get the exact same thing stored on
your disk
that the camera actually saw that's what
the raw format is for
so high-end cameras have a raw format
that will
store the original image that the camera
saw when you took took the photograph
other cameras and phones are going to do
some compression they'll say
well i can use this mathematical formula
that's part of jpeg or that's part of
heic
that's going to greatly reduce the
amount of space that this image is going
to store
and most people are not going to notice
these compression artifacts at all
so let's go ahead and do that
okay so our next format is png png
stands for portable network graphics
although as with jpeg
probably very few people know what png
stands for they just refer to them as
pngs
png's is a relatively new format it
builds on an older format referred to as
gif which we will take a look at in a
minute
pngs and gifs are both designed to store
diagrams
and graphics so what i mean by this is
they're designed to store images that
are generated by hand
or with computer graphics as opposed to
photographs
pngs and gifs both use a technique very
similar to that technique that we talked
about earlier with the h where i said
oh what we're going to do is we're going
to reduce the amount of space this takes
by looking at sections which are exactly
the same
so if you think about a photograph there
really aren't parts of the photograph
where you can say well that pixel this
set of pixels over here in the top left
is exactly the same as the pixels on the
on
on the right so you know maybe you can
say well this section is all ocean and
it's more or less the same
but it's not exactly the same whereas on
a diagram
you can definitely say well this line on
the diagram is exactly the same as this
other line in the diagram or
you know this section up here is exactly
the same as this other section and so
that's really the way png's and gifs
work they're looking for those sections
that are exactly the same
so you can take a photograph and you can
store it as a png but it's not very
efficient
the jpeg format and the technique used
for the jpeg compression is specifically
designed
for photographs and it's designed to
store photographs efficiently
the png technique and the gif technique
is specifically designed
to allow you to store diagrams in an
efficient manner
in contrast with the jpegs though the
png format is
not lossy so you know just as with our h
example where
you know i changed how i was describing
the h to the ta
and even though i was describing that h
in a different way where i'm like oh
that line's the same as the next line
these four lines here they're exactly
the same um these pixels here are the
same as this other
section of pixels over there you know if
i'm describing
the image to the ta in that manner i'm
not actually losing any information i'm
just changing
how it's being described they are still
able to reproduce the exact image that
we started with
and so that's the way png's and gifts
work they're going to be able to give us
an exact reproduction
of the original but they're going to
take up less space than
actually storing each of the individual
pixels
now png's and gifs do have
another interesting feature that's not
available in jpeg and this is the
ability to make some of the individual
pixels transparent
so let me show you how this works so
what we've got here is we've got the
stanford seal
and i'm showing it over a white
background and you can see that
the seal fits in very nicely here and it
looks like it matches really nicely
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take the stamper steel and put
it on a gray background and you can see
that
what's happened here is i can see that
the seal even though the seal is a
circle i can see that
i'm actually taking the seal along with
the rectangle surrounding the seal
and so the white background is really
going to show up here
so what i'm going to be able to do with
pngs or gifs
is i'm going to be able to designate
certain pixels
as being transparent which means
whatever is behind it will show up
instead of
worrying about what what is in the
diagram itself so um here we go
you can see i've have a transparent
version of the seal where
i've gotten rid of the parts of the
rectangle that aren't directly inside of
the
the circle and the seal and you can see
i've gotten rid of the interior of the
seal as well
and so i can put this over a variety of
different backgrounds so here it is in
front of gray
and you'll recall last lecture uh we
talked about
creating colors like see green here it
is in front of seed green
here is in front of tomato and burly
wood
and so i can put this seal in front of
lots of different backgrounds
and the pixels that are marked as
transparent will go ahead show
whatever's underneath them
in most editing programs that when
you're working with a format that does
support transparency the transparent
sections will show up as a checkerboard
pattern
so this is what the seal would look like
with no
transparency and this is what the seal
looks like with transparency
in adobe photoshop okay we've got one
last format that we need to cover
and that's gif gif is famous because
it allows us to create small animations
um this is essentially a series of still
images
packed together into the same file that
are played one image followed by the
next image followed by the next image so
this isn't really
full video video formats are a bit
different and they're going to be more
efficient if you've got
a whole bunch of video that you want to
shoot you don't really want to use gif
for for anything particularly long
um gif actually can be replaced now by
animated png but support for animated
png
is relatively recent there's still a lot
of web browsers out there
that aren't going to be able to show
your animated png so
if you want everybody to be able to see
your short little animate loop you
should go ahead and use gif
gif as an older format only supports 256
colors as opposed to the 16.7
million colors we've been using so
you'll notice that a lot of gifs seem a
little bit pixelated and that's because
they don't really have quite as many
colors as you would want in order to
provide a really nicely done scene
they do support transparency similar to
pngs but really
they've been overtaken by pngs the main
reason why you would run into them is
these short little animated loops and
they actually do show up as you've
probably seen
quite a bit on the web all right
the next lecture will be our last
lecture on how computers represent
information and in that lecture we're
going to take a look at how
computers represent sounds and music
i'll see you soon
you